[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
emotional text messages from friends of
dylan redwine as they search for the 13
year old
i have loved you too this day and it
breaks my heart to know you're gone
his father now on trial accused of
murdering his son
after the boy found compromising photos
of mark redwine
plus derek showman will learn his fate
an attorney for george floyd's family
on what they would consider a fair
punishment brother versus brother
a trial date now set for one of the
defendants in the pike county massacre
this case kind of took a 180.
one way george wagner plans to defend
himself against his younger brother's
claims
and the robber durst trial on hold the
break
as shocking testimony puts the defendant
near the crime scene
when susan berman was murdered law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a loving father or an enraged man who
killed his son
those are the portraits being painted of
mark redwine in a colorado courtroom
law and crime's angelette levy is here
with the first witness to testify
about the disappearance of dylan redwine
yeah brian the video that you're about
to see looks a lot different than what
we would usually show you because it
comes from a web system that the court
is allowing the public to use to watch
the trial
on the first full day of testimony the
jury heard from friends of dylan
redwines
about the last text messages they ever
sent him
dylan redwine was 13 years old in 2012
and texted with his friends frequently
feeling ever talk about
running away or hurting himself during
his friendship with you
never no on november 18th dylan was on a
court-ordered visit with his father
mark redwine over the thanksgiving
holiday ryan nava said he was expecting
dylan to come to his grandmother's home
early the next morning when you woke up
and you realized
dylan was not there what did you do i i
got up and i went outside
to look for him maybe he was sitting out
on the we have a patio area
um like i said he's familiar with that
part of my grandmother's home
so i went outside and um i took a look
around
going there no sir prosecutors claim
mark redwine killed his son
sometime on november 18 2012 possibly
after dylan confronted his father
about photos of him wearing women's
clothes and eating feces out of a diaper
but redwine's lawyers say mark redwine
is innocent
and that dylan may have been abducted or
run off
you told the fbi agent you knew dylan
was not scared to hitchhike
yeah yeah i remember saying that amanda
saxton broke down as she read from a
text that she sent to dylan
who called her kitty i promise i will
find you
and that's a promise i'm willing to keep
until the day i die i love you
the defense questioned saxton about how
dylan might react to a bad situation
you know from from watching dylan from
talking to him from
going through childhood together that if
he got angry or upset
it wasn't uncommon for him to just walk
away from the situation correct
yes
and the defense is suggesting that dylan
may have encountered some type of
situation
and simply walked away or run away or
maybe that somebody else
injured him redwine's attorney said in
opening statements that there was damage
from
animals to dylan's remains his skull was
actually found
a distance from his the rest of his body
brian thanks ange joining us today is
civil rights attorney jeff
storms and terry austin jeff what do you
make of the defense
that someone may have abducted dylan or
a bearer or lion
got involved it's a doubt but does it
sound reasonable
well brian with respect to the animal
the first thing i'll say
is this is taking place in durango
colorado which is
gorgeous and i don't think we should
fear the animals
uh very much hiking in durango colorado
death by a cougar or a bear is extremely
rare
uh far more rare than a murder and here
we have a very
clear motive and explanation and so i
think
you know you're looking at a typical
distraction
argument and i don't know that it's
going to be enough to raise any sort of
reasonable doubt
now dylan was 13 at the time it's nine
years later so some of these witnesses
are
in their early 20s terry how were these
witnesses so far
especially the young adults who are
testifying did either side
bring up strong points for their
argument well i think
both of them did a great job that i've
seen so far both ryan and amanda saxon
i mean they were 13 at the time 22 now
that's still extremely young if you
think about it
and they did establish the fact that
even though there might have been some
rowdiness as far as dylan was concerned
he was a fun-loving child
he was a normal child they had normal
banter back and forth so
i definitely think the prosecution is
trying to establish that he was a normal
child
that he wouldn't just take off and not
tell anybody
so i think that was important makes
sense and jeanette in the openings
the prosecution pointed to the lack of
concern redwine had
in searching for dylan did that seem
like strong evidence to you
yeah and you know there's going to be
more about that there will be testimony
about that
i spoke with dylan redwine's mom you
might recall last week and she said that
he was not
involved in the searches for their son
and i can tell you that's just not
normal behavior for a parent of course
everyone reacts to things differently
but i can tell you from my experience as
a mom
you know my child ran away from me my
son ran away from me in a shoe store one
time and i couldn't find him for a
couple of minutes and my heart was just
pounding and i was frantically looking
for him so
i think his demeanor will be important
in this case
absolutely i know they made comments
about his light being on and whether or
not
he came back but if the underlying issue
is that he's eating feces out of a
diaper maybe he doesn't react to most
things like the rest of us would
we'll see how the defense makes that
argument though still ahead on law and
crime daily the deadly custody battle
turning brother
against brother but first we break down
derek showman's upcoming sentence we
asked george floyd's family attorney
how much they want the former cop to be
spending in prison next
[Music]
welcome back former minneapolis police
officer derek showman
is scheduled to be sentenced this friday
as attorneys are still arguing about how
much time he should get
for the murder of george floyd derek
shoving faces up to 40 years in prison
in court documents prosecutors are
asking judge peter cahill to sentence
him to 30 years
his defense is requesting time served
and probation a jury convicted chauvin
of second degree murder
third degree murder and second degree
manslaughter at the sentencing hearing
george floyd's family will have the
opportunity to give victim impact
statements
chauvin's defense can present mitigating
factors for why they say
he should spend less time behind bars
then it'll be up to judge cahill to
decide
back with us is jeff storms who
represents george floyd's family
jeff right off the bat what does the
family want here
well you know brian we speak a lot on
behalf of our clients and this is one of
the weeks where the clients actually are
the ones who get to speak
so i don't want to say things that the
clients are going to have the
opportunity to say themselves
but it's fair to say that full justice
for this family full criminal justice
doesn't stop at the conviction it stops
at a sentence
that's significant and shows that
there is a punishment that fits the
crime you have to remember this is a
black family
who for years has watched members of
their community
be sentenced to very severe uh you know
sentences for uh very minimal crimes you
know we're talking about generations who
have grown up through three strikes laws
and things like that so you can
certainly anticipate that you're going
to hear from the family
that they want there to be a very strong
sentence for
derek shovin now during our time when i
know we met in minnesota together
we saw many family members speaking
about the sentencing here
who from the family is expected to speak
during these victim impact statements
you know unfortunately brian that's one
of the things i really can't address
directly right now but i think what the
viewers might find interesting and be a
little surprised by
is that there are also going to be
community impact statements
uh that are going to come forward as
part of the aggravating factors we call
them blakely factors in minnesota
you know derek chovin's murder of george
floyd
resulted in protests
and damage to property and impacted the
community in such a severe emotional way
and all of that stems from derek
shovin's murder and so what's going to
be unusual is for
you know viewers to hear about community
impact statements that were provided
to the court that the court's going to
consider as part of the sentencing
in addition to those family members who
will address
the court now jeff i've heard yourself
as well as attorney benjamin crump
talk about getting justice both in the
civil arena and then the criminal
in this case george floyd is getting
both so does derek shoving sentencing
mean closure for the family you know not
yet
brian the job's just not done yet you
know there's still a federal charge
against derek chovin that has to be
dealt with and there are the other three
officers
who all still have pending state and
federal charges
so this family still has a long road to
go
and so does the prosecution team for
attorney general keith ellison
and for the feds as well so we're still
uh
you know we're still in some ways only
the middle of this fight for complete
justice for george floyd
now as we both know there are two roads
here there's a state road and a federal
road
uh in terms of that federal road what
does the is the family looking forward
to
uh for the federal case you know
i think again i think that the family's
looking for the most comprehensive
justice
possible and you know you'll hear from
them this week about what their opinions
might be and they could be diverse in
terms of sentencing
but you know the federal civil rights
case is a case
that's based upon race and an intent
based upon race
and the family believes very strongly
that that's what happened
here and that a federal conviction or
guilty plea would be very
uh would fit uh the crime that derek
chovin committed uh
very well now jeff as a public defender
in brooklyn when i read
what the defense was asking for in terms
of sentencing
time served in probation i had a
reaction to that i wonder what your
reaction to that was
when you heard as to what the defense
was requesting in terms of sentencing
for derek chovin
i think everybody knows that that's a
laughable request and it's not going to
happen right
none of us ever say that uh something
happens with 100 certainty but i feel
pretty close to saying with 100
certainty that is not going to be the
sentence here
you know here the presumptive sentence
based upon our guidelines
in minnesota is 150 months but that's
before
enhancements uh and so i i have a
feeling that you're going to
see a sentence that looks much closer to
20-plus years
uh based upon history here in minnesota
and what we saw in the case
thank you very much jeff and make sure
to watch law and crime network we'll be
covering the sentence
of derek chovin on friday thank you
again
coming up on law on crime daily the
trial of robert durst and
more of the shocking testimony from one
of his close friends
plus the pike county massacre the trial
date set for one of the defendants
as his own brother implicates him in the
deaths of eight members of one family
more on this deadly custody battle next
a trial date has been set for one of the
four people charged
in the pike county massacre where eight
members of a family were killed in one
night angenette levy has followed the
case
since day one and is back with the
latest arguments in george wagner's case
george wagner is jake wagner's older
brother his lawyers say
that they are still waiting for
prosecutors to give them a copy
of jake wagner's confession to
investigators
we will certainly comply with our
discovery obligations
as the court is aware this case kind of
took a 180
about two months ago george wagner's
attorneys have requested new evidence
acquired by prosecutors
including more than 10 hours of
recordings with his younger brother
jake prosecutors say jake confessed to
the rodent and gilly murders and
implicated his family the defense claims
they haven't received the recordings
i think we need more than 60 days to
investigate
whatever we learned jake's profit
because we've not been provided that
even though it's been available for two
months but in court documents the
prosecution
called the defense arguments that
evidence hasn't been turned over
vexatious and moot they say they
discussed meeting with the defense to
turn over the evidence earlier this
month
and actually provided some of it last
week
the judge has scheduled a trial date for
george wagner
for april 4th of next year
now george wagner's attorneys have also
requested through a subpoena the medical
records
and mental health records of jake wagner
and they've kind of implied that he may
be a liar since he's changed his story
from
pre-arrest to now following the
indictment
uh george or jake wagner's attorneys
rather have asked the court
to quash that subpoena basically making
saying
make it go away brian interesting
developments angenette thank you
let's bring back civil rights attorney
jeff storms and co-host terry austin
terry jake wagner admitted that the
motive was about getting custody over
his daughter
and that's why so many were killed does
that seem a little over the top
you know what brian that is a huge
understatement yes it is over the top
listen having custody of a child there
is
no excuse for killing anyone but for
killing an entire family i think
it was delusional to believe that if you
kill an entire family you will get
custody of the child
obviously it is a crime of passion
obviously if there are so many people
killed in so many different places
it is a family who's involved or
multiple people
and so i think obviously tying it back
to
the parent is going to not give that
person
custody so i i think it was delusional
i would agree i think that's the right
word to describe that jeff would jake
wagner pleading guilty to
all 22 counts does this open the
floodgates for the family to turn on him
and blame jake for the murders
uh yeah i i certainly think it does
present the opportunity for the
the floodgates to open at that point and
i
might be the at the least resistance for
the uh
family now angela you've covered this
case for
years what do you see as george wagner's
options here
well you know the death penalty was
taken off the table jake agreed to
testify and as part of that agreement
uh the death penalty was taken off the
table for all family members so
george wagner either rolls the dice and
goes to trial and gets life in prison
or he pleads guilty and he gets life in
prison i don't see that he really has
any leverage at this point
against anyone so i don't think he has
many great options i guess he could roll
the dice and hope to maybe hang a jury
or
even get acquitted yeah and as we see we
have george waringer coming up first
obviously other defendants possibly
coming up so
i don't know like you said roll the dice
see how this plays out because his
options are pretty limited here
thank you everyone when we come back why
the trial of robert durst wasn't in
session on tuesday
and why his close friend recanted about
his whereabouts the night that susan
berman was murdered
welcome back the trial of robert durst
was on pause tuesday
the real estate heir accused of
murdering his best friend has a doctor's
appointment for a cardio test this break
comes in the middle of testimony from a
close friend of robert durst
emily altman is the wife of a former
attorney of robert durst and is
considered a close friend
in her pre-recorded testimony from 2017
altman said that robert durst was in los
angeles at the time of susan berman's
death
that shocking admission was two years
before durst would admit
to being the author of the now infamous
cadaver note she later recanted that
statement
after having a discussion with her
husband who told her he remembered
things
differently at the time
[Music]
with respect to your testimony
[Music]
and so are you saying that what
it was that your husband told you you
were wrong
once cross-examination began altman
spoke out about how
loon was pressuring her on the stand
which ultimately led her to give
false information about durst's
whereabouts
[Music]
looking directly at me making eye
contact and if she's
speaking to me directly okay
jeff susan chris presided over the texas
trial for the death of morris black in
which robert derse
was acquitted she spoke with law and
crime as to why robert duran's friends
seem so willing to help him
number one you've got these close
friends of his that
covered for him in spite of overwhelming
evidence that he had to be implicated
and not one but three different murders
okay and they
justify it do they justify it because
they love him do they justify it because
he's so rich but they go through this
mental gymnastics to try to justify
everything he says and does and to help
him perpetuate
his innocence to get away with it
jeff from the looks of it and what the
judge is saying it looks like these
witnesses
are almost so enamored by dirt that
they're willing to hide the body for him
could that be a successful strategy for
prosecutor john lewin in this case
well certainly i mean it raises doubt uh
for the
the credibility of any testimony that
you might hear right
that's being offered in order to uh
defend
jurors uh you know it's surprising to
hear that in some ways because
it would seem like these folks should
have seen enough evidence by now to know
his friends probably don't get treated
very well
but it certainly uh would seem like the
strategy is successful so far
yeah and i would love to see lewin turn
it around and say they've got to make
these lies because look at the last
friend who was about to tell on him
susan berman i think it might be a good
argument come summation we'll see how
that plays out though
terry altman gives the prosecution that
durst was in california
at the time berman disappeared did he
score any additional big points with
this testimony
i mean overall brian he scored points
because he did show like jeff said that
altman was extremely close to durst she
stuck by his side even through all these
disappearances and murders
but i think also we got a couple of
other points for the prosecution
one was that when altman asked
bob to do her a favor to get her son
a job he declined and she was not happy
about that so it showed that durst was
only looking out for himself
and i think the other point that lewin
made here
was durst was unfaithful and altman
testified that
she confirmed that he was unfaithful so
i think there was another small point
there
so overall i think altman was a good
witness for the prosecution
and clearly they would do anything for
him
but he didn't do that in return for them
yeah
we'll see how this plays out for robert
durs of course on tuesday as we said
he was out for a cardio test thank you
jeff thank you terry
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you